unsere helden sind diener und kevin
schmidt mit ihren kindern amira und ron
ihre neue heimat ist australien
[Musik]
der ehemalige tagesschau moderator hans
jörg enz sein abenteuer führt ihn in den
kongo monika und reto mazzoni mit den
töchtern chiara und celina sie leben nun
im wüsten emirat dubai sandra und danken
gano die beiden führen eine farm in
kanada und theres pronet und claudio
candrian ihr traumziel ein eigenes haus
auf der karibik insel margarita
[Musik]
die idyllische morgenstimmung in alice
springs mitten in der wüste australiens
weniger idyllisch geht es bei unseren
australien auswandern den schmidts tut
er das recht hat vater peter hammacher
spiele
[Musik]
sie stiegen mit der frage wo kommen
in der demokratischen republik kongo ist
hansjörg enz unterwegs in ein dorf im
kongolesischen hinterland er will heute
ein mädchen besuchen für das er seit
seinem aufenthalt im kongo eine
patenschaft übernommen hat und seit
kurzem die schule bezahlt der
schuldirektor persönlich empfängt ihn
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der schulbesuch ist im kongo ein luxus
den sich nur wenige eltern für ihre
kinder leisten kann als effizient gab
das sieht es mir zweiter sieg hattrick
seit sich mit geld übrigens sehen kein
einziges stück zu belassen
und wenn es geld hängt denn den hund vor
dem eltern und älteren dann kreisen
da hat so folgt oder seit sie in die
lehre dreimal pro tag vergessen und
einfach nicht was es ist was ist
geschehen
[Applaus]
in der pause trifft hansjörg enz sein
patenkind ziehen ihre total und amerika
hansjörg enz als einziges von sieben
kindern der familie zur schule gehen für
sie in ihre sechs geschwister können
sich die eltern das schulgeld nicht
leisten
sie spiegeln
getränke mit hubräumen hin
[Musik]
karibik-traum isla margarita für unsere
venezuela auswanderer könnte er zum
alptraum werden
seit ihrer ankunft zittern sie ob es mit
dem landkauf ihr traumhaus klappt wieder
einmal soll heute der vertrag für das
land unterschrieben werden
und heute treffen claudio candrian und
theres pronet die land verkäuferin
persönlich eine italienerin und auf die
sind die beiden gar nicht gut zu
sprechen
dreimal mehr als ursprünglich abgemacht
das sind rund 60000 franken
so viel müssen die beiden für ihr
grundstück bezahlen
[Musik]
preistreiberei dubiose vermittler und
immer wieder rückschläge hat die
leidensgeschichte für claudio candrian
und der ispo net jetzt endlich ein ende
[Musik]
10 mio eur und im musikhaus stolze
besitzer vor dem der trainer aber ich
bin so schlussstrich dass wir richtig
wenn man das und das hat mir so richtig
richtig froh und sehr stolz gemacht
haben wie heiko bin ich bin grad hin zum
kühlschrank und haben
[Musik]
am abend dann ist es endlich soweit der
anwalt bringt den unterschriebenen und
beglaubigten vertrag daher wichtig ist
auch die zinssätze in venezuela
[Musik]
sie spiegeln die decke mit davon
gekommen
[Musik]
bei den macho nis im wüsten emirat dubai
herrscht immer noch so etwas wie
ferienstimmung
die kinder haben noch keine schule und
so geht man auf den arabischen markt den
zug
[Applaus]
ich glaube dass das geht einfach nicht
ich denke
wobei ja
das connect um das ist ja was zahlreiche
händler
auch in dubai der tat um den preis
gefeilscht
[Musik]
monika treibt die verkäuferin zu
verzweifeln
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
roger becker
bald ist die ferienzeit vorbei
den kindern steht der erste schultag in
der fremden heimat bevor
sie schicken ihre werke mit der
vollkommen in kanada haben sandra und
danken gano zwar jetzt eine farm aber
immer noch keine kühe
denn die gehen an der versteigerung in
sein tross eine nach der anderen zu viel
zu hohen preisen weg da kann duncan mit
seinem budget nicht mithalten
der zeuge
doch dann kommt sie die chance bei
dieser älteren kuh bietet danken kapfer
mit
und bekommt schließlich den zuschlag
ist dies der erste schritt zu einer
großen herde danken ersteigert nun eine
kuh nach der anderen sechs insgesamt
[Musik]
auftakt am gleichen abend noch treffen
sie ein
die ersten sechs trächtigen mutterkühe
[Musik]
alle tragen sie ein calvin sich wichtige
startkapital für sandra danken
dafür komme schon lästig ist dass das
jetzt sind einige zum auf
[Musik]
der zick zack kurs gekauft
angestellt
weit über 100 kühe brauchen sie noch
damit ihren traum als farmer in kanada
leben können
sie stiegen funke mit alpha group wurde
[Musik]
am anderen ende der welt in australiens
wüste schlagen sich die schmidts mit
weit weniger angenehmen tieren herum
der besucher wird im internet gegoogelt
der biss der huntsman spinne ist nicht
lebensbedrohlich kann aber offenbar
kopfschmerzen und erbrechen verursachen
das steht uns sympathisch sie aber im
grund nämlich dass sie beim fahren
wenn die
[Musik]
bei ihrem eintreffen überwinden auch
gebraucht damit der inhalt kommt man ins
vorstellen dass sie das
im kongo ist entwicklungshelfer hansjörg
enz mittlerweile eine berühmtheit
geworden
heute muss er dem lokalsender radio
television gralla kein fernseh interview
geben
der direktor persönlich sagt hansjörg
enz das improvisierte studios erzählt
dem stolz vor seiner fernsehkarriere in
der schweiz
[Musik]
das interview im steinzeit studio für
hansjörg enz wie eine reise in die
vergangenheit
[Gelächter]
ähnlich ursprünglich geht es in
venezuela einen tag vor heiligabend zu
und her
[Musik]
dollar
claudio candrian ist zu besuch bei
seinem freund papier claudio darf
zuschauen wie der weihnachtsbraten
geschlachtet wird claudio bleibt lieber
etwas auf die straße und seine frau
teresa hat er wohlweislich zu hause
gelassen
[Musik]
und dann kommt weihnachten 2008 für
claudio und er es das erste
weihnachtsfest auf ihrer trauminsel das
erste als landbesitzer
mit dem fressen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
am abend sind die beiden bei peyo tanz
und nicht zu voll geborgen jung sondern
eben zu schweinebraten eingeladen
[Musik]
ja
am wahrscheinlichsten
[Musik]
das merken vor ganz schnell
claudia york mit
nehmen
dafür
[Musik]
in dubai bei sonys geht es nun ernst für
chiara und selina
der erste schultag in der green viel
community school steht bevor
die klassenlehrerinnen mit lugner
erklärt selina was heute passiert doch
diese versteht kaum etwas
wie alt bist du 10
dann ist dein geburtstag
wendige wurzeln
das kann den ernst
und 20
[Applaus]
es ist doch aufnehmen wie wird es wohl
klar gehen wenigstens ist ihre
klassenlehrerin eine deutsche für die
erste stunde bist du für dich ist der
sturm habe dir deine schwester schon
abgegeben
und die arena ist noch etwas verloren
das ist selina sie kommt aus der schweiz
sie spricht noch ganz wenig englisch ich
möchte dass du dich und celina kümmerst
mathilda und er zeigt wo turnen
französisch und deutsch stattfinden
miss lohan arnim celina gleich unter
ihre fittiche und testet ihre
englischkenntnisse und chiara
wenn nämlich kern und land ist
bei herpes ist in berlin
and how und ist
[Musik]
ja
dabei denkt daran wie es vielen von euch
ging als ihr ohne englisch zu verstehen
nach dubai gekommen seid als ihr kaum
etwas verstanden was glaubt ihr können
wir machen um klare zu helfen
wir können ja alles erklären gut jahre
soll teil unseres teams sein
[Musik]
und auch selina gehört immer mehr zu
einem team
[Musik]
ich alleine
gegen bissingen wollen
nicht umsonst heißt es im lied wir sind
nur ein kleiner teil der welt aber
gemeinsam sind wir stark und haben
nichts zu fürchten
[Musik]
trotzdem
und chiara hat schon eine erste freundin
gefunden
jk
und nachdem es mit der musik seines
klienten macht fast seinen flug
verantwortlich fest ich kann ihr vater
na ja
zurück nach kanada die sechs mutter für
scheinen sich wohl zu fühlen bei den
garaus
[Musik]
und wohl fühlt sich auch der neueste
familienzuwachs garros haben von den
nachbarn den hund mit geschenkt bekommen
familienzuwachs ist verdanken sowieso
ein dauerthema
ein hai christina vielleicht das war
habe ich glaub's nicht billigen
sie lenken ja wenn den schotten
herrschte einigkeit
ja das war schon praktisch immer klappt
es nicht
im prinzip
das match ist endlich mal die moschee
herstellern und machen mit
publik
[Musik]
am anderen ende der welt in australien
ist es kein guter morgen für diener
schmid ehemann und touristen guide cabot
muss wieder einmal weg er packt für eine
zweitägige tour zurück bleibt die mit
den kindern
[Musik]
die beamten schützten sich die menschen
sehr genau weiß ich nicht was letztmalig
man weiß es nicht
[Musik]
jede
katys über 20 tage pro monat unterwegs
eine belastende situation für diener und
die kinder auch eine rückkehr stand
schon zur diskussion
und sie
da die haben sie depressiv
so hat
pauli
wer den schuss seite
dagegen der 1
wo es bei
wenn wir das diskutiert was eine echte
gefahr
kate arbeitet als tourguide im
australischen outback heute betreute
eine siebenköpfige touristengruppe aus
der schweiz
das sind oben kilometer unbefestigte
straßen sind mindest oder hafer und
china
[Musik]
gekürzt
langsam bewegen noch drauf
[Musik]
meine lieblingsbeschäftigung bei knapp
40 grad
doch auch das gehört zum job
[Musik]
apple fährt mit seiner siebenköpfigen
schweizer gruppe tief ins australische
outback
[Musik]
aber die machen gar nicht denken
aber das ist immer ratsam sein alter
klub im outback gewisse ausstrahlung
riefen großmann suizidenten neuen orden
ist derzeit das lange bevor herr klöster
bekommen überhaupt möglich wäre dass die
schau gerätekauf hinterland und dann
gehen auch im busch
[Musik]
wird die junge familie in australien ihr
glück finden
großer tag wie hansjörg enz im kongo
[Applaus]
ich gehe zum 31 der fuß unterwegs als
sein eigenes ego das natürlich zu zimmer
haben kuchen isst gern dass im hauptraum
davids faschistisch da gibt es den hund
ice wurde beschuss das kuki da könnte
man auch eine ganze armee warum die hoch
ist die mixtur dass trainer reiner barg
sie da ist
hinter dem user nach einem einem messias
kronanwalt nichts deshalb ist es einfach
dosiertes genialer doch boka wo ist
nicht ascona oder nizza nach dem gang in
die schlafzimmer im ersten stock sinkt
die begeisterung etwas
die zimmer sind schmuddelig und ihnen
desolate zustand
scheiße wir haben das vorgestellt ich ja
waren das ab macht sie aber man muss
realistisch ist doch genauso wie sich
aber klar ist ich konnte mir die fragen
oder und und und eine woche lang sind
dafür werden nicht ganz korrekt
ein trost bleibt entwicklungshelfer 1
die atemberaubende aussicht
zur gleichen zeit in venezuela auf der
karibik insel margarita claudio candrian
und theres boot fahren zu ihren neuen
grundstück
denn heute sollen die bauarbeiten an
ihrem traumhaus beginnen
so
doch wieder einmal kommt alles anders
nichts läuft hilfe und freund peter
erklärt warum nichts läuft heute sei
feiertag und der baggerfahrer wolle erst
geld ziehen bevor er überhaupt zu
arbeiten anfangen
diese basieren denkt lässt hören die sie
hervor des gelddruckens nicht nötig zu
schaffen
wenn du so oft gar nichts bringen nach
unten weil ich das ist schon jetzt
einmal mehr leerlauf und ärger für die
venezuela auswanderer macho nichts
dagegen haben mitten in der wüste in
dieser grünen oase in der greenfield
community von dubai ihr traumhaus
gefunden
nach drei monaten können sie endlich aus
dem engl hotel appartement ausziehen
die glocken angeboten
[Musik]
die suche nach einem haus gestaltete
sich auch in dubai schwierig immer
wieder scheiterte es am preis oder an
komplizierten verhandlungen nach einer
schönen hätte und das ist wirklich
seriösen sind muss ich sagen
nun können endlich auch die möbel aus
der schweiz geliefert werden die in
einem container zwischen gelagert waren
etc
ja auch aus
meist noch etwas zusammen
selina freut sich schon auf ihr heiß
geliebtes klavier im zimmer doch dann
kommt die enttäuschung für selina die
zügel männer wollen das klavier nicht in
den ersten stock hoch tragen kleine der
starken vertrag hatte sich blake lassen
kannst du diskussionen und ergebnis und
alle sind genervt wenn sie jetzt sagen
sie ja auch nicht so gross wie die
schweiz
[Musik]
waren es die tränen selinas oder die
hartnäckigkeit von monika schließlich
klappt es doch mit dem klavier
[Applaus]
sie ist so glücklich jetzt sie musste
beinen vorher denn das war ihr traum das
klavier im eigenen zimmer
endlich hat die familie mazzoni ihr
eigenes heim und monika und reto nach
all den stressigen monaten einen moment
für zweisamkeit leningrad dass die
akteure sich nicht einfach mal so
verliebtheit das ist wirklich es ist am
in russland eröffnen und sehr gute
antworten
die familie mazzoni scheint ihr glück in
dubai gefunden zu haben
[Musik]
auch in kanada entwickelt sich alles
prächtig sandra danken gar haben
inzwischen 140 muttertier gekauft
[Musik]
ja ich mache zehn kleine kälber sind
schon auf die welt gekommen
[Musik]
und heute ist wohl kalk nummer 11 an der
reihe
[Musik]
duncan und die kuh warten geduldig ja es
kommt
duncan ist verunsichert lebt das kalb
[Applaus]
dank die erleichterung kalb nummer 11
lebt
haupt dankt es ihr zu danken farmer
leben in der nächsten folge sehen sie
auch nächste woche bei auf und davon
in venezuela fangen endlich die
bauarbeiten ab traumhaus von claudio und
theresa in australien bringt ketsch mit
seiner tochter amira den richtigen
umgang mit giftschlangen bei
in dubai beginnt monicelli einen neuen
job als masseurin
[Musik]
laufen im kongo entdeckt hansjörg enz
bilder gorillas in schulen
[Musik]